Yes,
you if you can elaborate a bit on,
you mentioned you talked about this
mental process where people do the thing
that's hard but less,
less hard,
but still basically shadow.
That's actually a really productive way
of procrastinating,
although it comes with its own problems
of rationalization,
so reinforces certain circuit.
I'll put it in a way that says that
those can go away,
so you need to bring up the.
The other inhibitory circuits.
Just wondering if you could elaborate.
Well,
I can sure is in the realm of
possibility around their understanding
that.
Well,
I've derived out partly from my study of
addiction and also from my study of
recovery from posttraumatic stress
disorder,
but let's talk about addiction.
So there's a series of actions that
occur before you take your cocaine.
Some of those are local.
They are the things that happened
immediately before and some of those are
distal.
They're farther back in the chain of
events and when you.
When you have a hit of cocaine,
it produces a dopaminergic burst and
that feels really good,
but it also makes the circuits that were
immediately active before that grow.
That's what reinforcement is,
and then the growth is proportionate,
not linearly,
but it's proportionate to how long
before that event occurred.
The closer it is,
the stronger they're going to get,
but even the ones that are somewhat
distal get some reinforcement because
you might say,
well,
what did you do before you,
you found your latest fix?
And the answer is,
well,
how long before?
Well,
the closer,
the more reward.
And so what happens then is that,
so if you take that person out of the
normal environment,
you put them into a treatment center,
they're off.
They're a physical addiction,
which is a weird thing in the case of
cocaine,
but I'm like not that long a week.
I'll do it two weeks for sure.
Even heroin and alcohol for sure,
if you can get them through the seizure
part without dying.
Um,
and so they're done.
They're physiologically dependent
anymore.
But you let that person go.
And the first thing that happens is his
old friend who he's always out doing
drugs with shows up and bang,
he's craving like mad.
And that's because that thing is in an
area is not dead at all and it's
activated by the queue and it's,
it's a circuit.
It's not.
It's a personality.
It only wants one thing at once.
Cocaine,
it's going to suppress any non related
thoughts and it'll use lies.
That's no problem.
Especially if lies have been reinforced,
which they certainly have.
Where are you off to sun,
you know you'll have a live for that and
then 10 minutes later you have your drug
and so that little lie has just grown.
Or maybe you think you've tried to quit.
You think to hell with it.
And every time,
10 minutes before you take your drug,
you think to hell with it.
And you do that a thousand times.
Well believe me that to hell with it,
circuit,
that sucker is strong.
And so it's alive and it's not like it
just disappears.
It can't,
it's you,
it's grown in there.
Now you can build another circuit to
shut it down and you can help decompose
across time by not giving it what it
wants,
but you're going to have to not give it
what it wants in all of the multiple
contexts that you've already associated
with the drug.
Some of you probably smoked and then
tried to quit smoking and what you'll
see is you get a craving when,
well,
when you have a cup of coffee or when
you're finished dinner,
when you're done having a phone call or
when you first get up in the morning or
whenever you've regularly had the drug,
whatever you had the drug in
relationship to even complex things like
ending a conversation will produce a
cute craving and so then that can
extinguish overtime if you punish it by
either punishing it or not letting it
get what it's wants,
but a lot you have to build another
circuit to just shut it down and then
that circuits kind of fragile and stress
can often disrupt it.
So
that can be read about quitting smoking
or things like,
oh sure.
Well,
part of it.
I begins a whole different thing because
it seems to have a direct physiological
effect,
but you know,
the,
the addiction has a cognitive component.
It's full of thoughts and desires and
wants and you know,
you may have to build,
you have,
may have to rebuild your whole
personality in order to,
to get that thing cornered.
Religious conversion for example,
is in a really effective treatment for
alcoholism.
That's partly why alcoholic alcoholics
anonymous works for the people for whom
it does work,
but religious conversion,
which is total personality conversion is
actually one of the few things that we
know of that's an effective treatment
for alcoholism.
We don't know how to induce it,
but although that's not exactly true
either because I'm in the early work
with Lsd was lsd was quite promising as
a treatment for,
for an alcohol addiction and there's
recent work with silicide button's
showing that if you,
if people have a mystical experience
when you give them Psilocybin,
their success rate and quitting smoking
is about 80 percent,
which is way higher than any
pharmacological intervention for smoking
has ever beat.
So.
Alright.
We should probably call it a day,
so we'll see you in a week.